ça y est la pure auchan vient de
démarrer
vous avez mûri dubois ce que oui j'ai
pas besoin de cela pour nom à des
marques et s'ils ont eu vendredi saint
c'est la pirouette l'avantagent avec ma
copine isa c'est que le vendredi ça pue
power une connerie dit une autre gratuit
derrière
vous la retrouvez sur rtl chaque matin
plus grande journaliste et les drailles
de radio truc m'a fait rire qu'est ce
qui vous a fait vraiment ses pieds en
plus aujourd'hui et oui aux mecs qu'ils
y étaient les élus sont deux ans avoue
que tout à l'heure jean michel à dire le
film a peu de moyens on dormait chez
l'habitant et pour une fois qu ils donc
pas dans habitants
bien
elle a eu un rapport sexuel avec thierry
moreau